[Music]
so i've mentioned before the campaign of
psychological warfare being waged
against me by my wife and children who
for years have been trying to coerce me
into funding and even accompanying them
on a trip to disney world
now we never went to disney world when i
was a kid our amusement park was a sheet
of plastic a grassy hill and a garden
hose homemade slip and slides never
worked like the store-bought version but
we made do
and we liked it too we didn't need no
dang fancy glorified carnival we ran
around outside all day without our shoes
on
came home for supper supper was a boiled
raccoon in a rusty pot and we liked that
too
and i would say mom can i at least have
some salt for the raccoon and she would
say boy you'll get some salt from those
tears when i whip your behind
this is how i lived or at least it's the
version that i tell my kids all the time
and i've tried to explain all this to
them perhaps taking poetic license with
one or two details but they're not
convinced mostly because their mother is
working against me sabotaging me every
step of the way and the end result is
that now we will be going to disney
world as i could no longer withstand the
pressure
my only hope is to keep putting off the
trip using various stalling tactics at
least until our youngest is 25 or so
already i've successfully convinced my
wife that we uh we can't go this spring
for
whatever reason i came up with obviously
we don't want to go in the summer it's
be too hot so instead let's shoot for
the fall and that gives me several
months to think of a reason why we can't
go in the fall either
maybe i'll say that we can't go because
it's election season and i have to stay
here and uh
watch the polls or whatever
but as horrifying as disney world will
surely be
whenever i'm finally forced to actually
go
it's only the tip of the iceberg here's
the latest an article from the verge it
says disney has launched a new business
for fans who can't bear to leave the
pristine family-friendly world the
corporation has nurtured through its
theme parks and media ventures story
living by disney will operate as part of
the company's theme parks division
developing a series of master-planned
communities for residential living
designed by disney's creative staff and
offering the same pampered tranquility
found in its resorts
one location has been announced so far a
community of 1900 housing units named
cotino that will be built in the city of
rancho mirage in california's coachella
valley concept art for catina shows
villas condos and housing complexes
clustered around a 24-acre grand oasis
which disney says will offer clear
turquoise water powered by the crystal
lagoons technology deployed at its
resorts amenities will include shopping
dining entertainment as well as a
beachfront hotel and clubhouse hosting
disney programming entertainment and
activities throughout the year
now this truly sounds like a fantastic
housing opportunity if you have so
despaired of your human existence that
you want to totally surrender yourself
to disney so that every aspect of your
life is subject to corporate programming
i mean even more than it already is
now if you think this sounds
horrifically dystopian like something
out of a black mirror episode wait until
you see the promotional video
i'm proud to announce our next disney
experience story living by disney all
new disney branded master planned
residential communities designed to be
the perfect setting for disney fans to
write the next exciting chapter in their
lives
and some neighborhoods will be planned
for residents ages 55 and over
story living by disney allows us to
leverage what we do best world-class
service legendary storytelling and
creativity
this exciting new venture will enhance
extend and strengthen the disney brand
by allowing us to bring the magic of
disney to places you may never have
expected
these vibrant communities will be
infused with disney place making picture
an energetic community with the warmth
and charm of a small town and the beauty
of a resort a place that entices
inspiration makes every moment more
memorable than the last a story living
by disney community is something truly
special
the charm of a small town except it's
owned by a company worth 200 billion
dollars now she says it's like a small
town but also like a resort
only a resort is a place where people
wait on you hand and foot and you're
subjected to so much unrelenting and
obtrusive comfort and luxury that it
quickly becomes exhausting in its own
special way
meanwhile a small town and i say this as
someone who just moved from one is a
place where you can live independently
and do things yourself and have some
semblance of privacy and have something
of your own
and experience the bonds of community in
a non-facilitated organic non-forced
kind of way
so a small town is the exact opposite of
a resort and that is its whole charm
still even if the small town pitch is
silly who wouldn't want to live in a
community dedicated to as we were told
enhancing the disney brand
these are surely the values we want to
pass on to our children when our
children ask us what it means to live in
a community and be a good neighbor we
can tell them that it means undying
fealty to a multinational corporate
brand and when our children ask us the
meaning of life we can tell them the
meaning of life is the brand
and when our children aren't satisfied
with that answer and begin to hunger for
a deeper and more authentic existence
we could tell them to come with us to
the disney doctor so he can give them
some special pills that will make all
those unpleasant ideas go away
you know i find myself more and more
having to remind people that the truman
show was not meant to be an instruction
manual
it's supposed to be a nightmare not a
dream come true it's a it's a dystopia
not a utopia
but this is probably where we're headed
as a country i mean in 10 years we'll
all be living in disneyville or amazon
land or walmart walmart town
and the worst thing about it is that
most people probably won't be real
enough by that point to be bothered by
how unreal and curated their everyday
life has become
again we already live in an unreal
curated reality and many people are not
nearly as bothered by it as they ought
to be in fact they like it
as much as they can like anything given
that their passions have been dulled as
they more and more turn into faceless
robotic consumers
as for disney specifically
you know lots of adults these days cling
obsessively to
not their childhoods as a whole but
specifically the brands and
entertainment franchises of their
childhoods
they're still adults like they're adults
complaining about
and they get really upset
complaining about the new pixar films
and and how the animation isn't as good
as it was you know when toy story first
came out
or you know these these new disney
movies they're not as good as
i don't like them as much as when i was
a kid that's because they're for kids
and the disney movies you saw when you
were a kid you were a kid when you
watched them
that's why you don't like them as much
now
because it's time to move on with your
life
and develop tastes that are suitable for
an adult
but those are the only things that they
remember about their childhoods that's
why they cling onto it it's how they
define their past and also their present
and their future
and so there will be unfortunately a
vast population eager to go live in a
community totally dedicated to the
corporate entertainment that has always
defined their lives and maybe it's for
the best
you know get get all those people in one
place segregate them
and then carve out the whole plot of
land and eject it into the sun
that would be my planet
and if we can't do that then at least we
can say to them that you're all
cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content